المدينه الاستراتيجيه من موسكو ينضم الينا
مراسل عباد مازن اهلا بك ابدا معك باخر
المعلومات حول عمليه التسلل التي تحدث
عنها رئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين رغم
نفيكياف تحدث بالتفصيل عن هذه العمليه
ماذا عباس هل تسمعنا
اسمعكم يعني الرئيس بوتين تحدث اليوم بدلا
من ان يتوجه الى مدينه
القى كلمه عبر الوسائل عبر اونلاين مع
هؤلاء الطلاب تحدثنا فيه عن هذه العمليه
التي وصفنا بالارهابيه انما هي تستهدف
يعني اصرار روسيا على
التنفيذ اهدافها في عملياتها العسكريه
ووصفها بالعمليه الارهابيه بحسب المعلومات
التي نقلت عن مصادر مقربه وايضا من
الاجهزه الامنيه الروسيه ان نحو 50
مقاتل اوكرانيا دخلوا الى منطقه بريانس
والقصر الى مجموعتين مجموعه توجهت للمدينه
لوبتشاني حيث اقتحمت مركز تجاري واحتجزت
العائل وتم القضاء على هذه المجموعه
واجبرتهم اجبرهم
القوات الامن الى اعلى الفرار نفس الوقت
المجموعه الثانيه توجهت الى مدينه شرانيه
اطلقت النار الشوارع بحسب المعلومات التي
نقلت عن مصادر مقربه من السلطات اقليم
برانس ان هذه المجموعات قامت باطلاق النار
ايضا على كاميرات المراقبه حتى يصعب رصد
تحركاتها هذا اذا حول عمليات التسلل من
جانب اخر طبعا المعارك في محيط بخموت ما
زالت عنيفه للغايه كيف تقول انها تتشبث
بهذه المدينه لكن هناك معلومات ايضا من
جانب الروس حول التقدم على مشارف
هناك يعني لا يمكن القول ان هناك تضارب
بالمعلومات بقدر بان المعلومات الرسميه لم
تتحدث حتى هذه اللحظه عن سيطره القوات
الروسيه على مدينه وان كان مجموعات نشرت
صور فيديو لي بعض المقاتليها في وسط
المدينه نائب اوكرانيا اعلن ان القوات
الروسيه اصبح تسيطر على المدينه من كافه
الاتجاهات في نفس الوقت الذي تحدث فيه
رئيس الوفد الروسي
بانه خلال الفتره القادمه ستحكم القوات
الروسيه الحصار حول مدينه بخبط وبالتالي
ستتمكن من السيطره عليها حتى الان ليس
لدينا تاكيدات رسميه من وزاره الدفاع او
من ايات الاركان الروسيه لانه تمت بالفعل
السيطره الكامل للقوات الروسيه على مدينه
معروف ان المعارك هناك شديده تدور وتمويه
وخاصه تعتبر مركز دعم للقوات الاوكرانيه
في منطقه
بس اذا كنت معنا من موسكوك